walking away this morning but that
question following him after the labour
leader found himself under police
investigation for an indoor gathering
with colleagues drinking beer and eating
curry
finally this afternoon his answer in a
hastily arranged news conference
i'm absolutely clear that no laws were
broken
they were followed at all times
i simply had something to eat
while working late in the evening
but if the police decide to issue me
with a fixed penalty notice
i would of course
do the right thing
and step down a big decision not made
lightly or quickly
why did it take you so long to arrive at
that position is it because you're aware
of the huge gamble that you're taking
and you were frightened by that unlike
those at downing street i don't think
those that make the laws can then simply
breach them i believe that if you've
made a law you should respect the law
and if you're found to be in breach of
it you should step down you know it's a
gamble for you though beth this is a
matter of principle and honour we
shouldn't all be dragged down
by this cynical belief that all
politicians are the same we've seen 50
fines in downing street we've seen a
prime minister won't step down we are
not all the same you said then that the
prime minister should resign because he
was under criminal investigation which
you now are as well
isn't it rather hypocritical
that you said that of him but you're not
prepared to resign right now i've set
out my position very clearly i've taken
a very different course to the prime
minister of course um did break the laws
and then didn't resign i'm setting out a
very different course
star mcclear has a different course but
the optics of his crisis quite similar
as his own criticisms of the pm come
back to haunt him when the whole country
was locked down he was hosting boozy
parties in downing street
is he now going to do the decent thing
and resign i don't think he has the
moral authority to lead and i think he
should go we now have the shameful
spectacle of a prime minister of the
united kingdom being subject to a police
investigation kirstama has built his
entire leadership around being a man of
principle and honor whilst trying to
cast boris johnson as a man of none so
this police investigation is a massive
problem for him and he and his allies
over the weekend decided that being
prepared to resign was the only way he
could put clear blue water between him
and the prime minister but it comes with
huge risk if durham police find that
there was a breach of the rules he's
gone
but the police aside what do the people
back in durham think like boris johnson
he should also
uh step down this has gone far too far
it's all got very very silly
and i think kirstjarma and boris johnson
maybe they should all step down
end off
the pm in downing street today hosting
the spring fair not going anywhere
none of it good for either man the
question is is it faithful beth rigby
sky news westminster